so aluminium is a metal which was only
isolated in the 19th century and when it
was first isolated it was fantastically
expensive it was displayed like gold at
exhibitions now you find it everywhere
for example you can find it quite easily
here on you have thin foil of aluminium
which is used as the covering for pill
packets you may easily read in lunch
today from sandwiches that were wrapped
up in aluminium foil and it's used in
the laboratories in all sorts of
different ways it's a very good
reflective material so chemists and
engineers often put aluminium coatings
on mirrors like this one usually if you
have a mirror in your bathroom the metal
coating is at the back so that when you
spit when cleaning your teeth you don't
damage the mirror but when you're doing
experiments particularly with
ultraviolet light that's absorbed by
glass you have the infrared light as
well you have this on as a coating on
the front of your mirror so in steer you
have quite nice example of a front
coated aluminium mirror